this is a rotifer it's a microorganism
about a hairs within size they live
everywhere on earth salt water and fresh
water everywhere and this one is out
looking for food so I remember the first
time I saw this thing I was like eight
years old and it completely blew me away
I mean here's this incredible little
creature it's hunting swimming going
about its life but its whole universe
fits within a drop of pond water so this
little rotifer shows us something really
amazing it says that you can build a
machine that is functional complex smart
but all in a tiny little package one so
small that it's impossible to see it now
the engineer in me is just blown away by
this thing that anyone could make such a
creature but right behind that wonder I
have to admit is a bit of envy I mean
nature can do it why can't we why can't
we build tiny robots well I'm not the
only one to have this idea in fact in
the last few years researchers around
the world have taken up the task of
trying to build robots that are so small
that they can't be seen and what we're
gonna tell you about today is an effort
at Cornell University and now at the
University of Pennsylvania to try to
build tiny robots okay so that's the
goal but how do we do it how do we go
about building tiny robots
well Pablo Picasso of all people gives
us our first clue
Picasso said
good art is copyright great artists
steal okay but steal from what well
believe it or not most of the technology
you need to build a tiny robot already
exists the semiconductor industry has
been getting better and better at making
tinier and tinier devices so that at
this point they could put something like
a million transistors into the size of a
package that is occupied by say a
single-cell Paramecium and it's not just
electronics they can also build little
sensors LEDs whole communication
packages that are too small to be seen
so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna steal that technology here's a
robot robots got two parts as it turns
out it's got a head and it's got legs
we're gonna call this a legless robot
okay which may sound exotic but they're
pretty cool all by themselves in fact
most of you have a legless robot with
you right now your smartphone is the
world's most successful legless robot in
just 15 years it has taken over the
entire planet and why not it's such a
beautiful little machine it's incredibly
intelligent
it's got great communication skills and
it's all in a package that you can hold
in your hand so we would like to be able
to build something like this only down
at the cellular scale the size of a
Paramecium and here it is this is our
cell sized smartphone it even kind of
looks like a smartphone only it's about
10,000 times smaller and we call it an
ohmic four optically wired integrated
circuit okay we're not advertisers all
right
but it's pretty cool all by itself
in fact this Oh egg has a number of
parts so up near the top there are these
cool little solar cells that you shine
light on the device and it wakes up a
little circuit that's there in the
middle and that circuit can drive in a
little tiny LED that can blink at you
and allows the oeq to communicate with
you so unlike your cell phone the oh it
communicates with light sort of like a
tiny Firefly now one thing that's pretty
cool about these oh exede in one at a
time soldering all the pieces together
we make them in massive parallel for
example about a million of these o
Xfinity Lake and just like your phone
has different apps you can have
different kinds of Oh X there can be
ones that say measure voltage some that
measure temperature or just have a
little light that can blink at you to
tell you that it's there so that's
pretty cool these tiny little devices
and I'd like to tell you about them in a
little more detail but first I have to
tell you about something else I'm gonna
tell you a few things about pennies that
you might not know so this one is a
little bit older penny it's got a
picture of the Lincoln Memorial on the
back but the first thing you might not
know that if you zoom in you'll find in
the center of this thing you can
actually see Abraham Lincoln just like
in the real Lincoln Memorial not so far
from here well I'm sure you don't know
that if you zoom in even further you'll
see that there's actually a Noack on Abe
Lincoln's chest but the cool thing is
you could stare at this all day long and
you would never see it it's invisible to
the naked eye these oh it's are so small
and we make them in such parallel
fashion that each oh it costs actually
less than a penny in fact the most
expensive thing in this demo is that
little sticker that says Oh egg
that cost about 8 cents now we're very
excited about these things for all sorts
of reasons for example we can use them
as little tiny secure smart tags more
identifying than a fingerprint we're
actually putting them inside of other
medical instruments to give other
information and even starting to think
about putting them in the brain to
listen to neurons one at a time in fact
there's only one thing wrong with these
o X it's not a robot it's just a head
and I think we'll all agree that half a
robot really isn't a robot at all
without the legs we've got basically
nothing okay so you need the legs too if
you want to build a robot now here it
turns out you can't just steal some
pre-existing technology if you want legs
for your tiny robot you need actuators
parts that move now they have to satisfy
a lot of different requirements so for
example they need to be low voltage it
need to be low power too but most
importantly they have to be small if you
want to build a cell sized robot you
need cell sized legs now nobody knows
how to build that there was no
pre-existing technology that meets all
of those demands to make our legs for
our tiny robots we had to make something
new so here's what we built this is one
of our actuators and I'm applying a
voltage to it when I do you can see the
actuator responds by curling up now this
might not look like much but if we were
to put a red blood cell up on the screen
Olivia about that big so these are
unbelievably tiny curls right they're
unbelievably small and yet this device
can just bend and unbend no problem
nothing breaks so how do we do it
well yeah trigger is made from a layer
of platinum just a dozen atoms are so
thick now it turns out that if you take
platinum and you put it in water and you
apply a voltage to it atoms from the
water will attach or remove themselves
from the surface of the Platinum
depending on how much voltage you use
this creates a force you can use that
force for voltage controlled actuation
the key here was to make everything
ultra thin then your actuators flexible
enough to bend for these small sizes
without breaking and it can use the
forces that come about from just
attaching and removing a single layer of
atoms now we don't have to build these
things one at a time either
in fact just like the O X we can build
them massively in parallel
well so here's a couple thousand or so
actuators and all I'm doing is applying
a voltage and they all wave looking like
nothing more than the legs of a future
robot army so now we got the brains and
we got the bronze we got the smarts and
the actuators the oh it's there the
brains they give us sensors they give us
power supplies and they give us a
two-way communication system via light
the Platinum layers they're the muscle
they're what's gonna move the robot
around now we can take those two pieces
put them together and start to build our
tiny tiny robots so the first thing we
want to build with something really
simple this is a robot that walks around
under user control in the middle are
some solar cells and some wiring
attached to it that's the O ik they're
connected to a set of legs which have a
platinum layer and then these rigid
panels that we put on top to tell the
legs how to fold up what shape they
should take the idea is that by shooting
a laser at the different solar cells you
can choose which leg you want to move
and make the robot walk around now of
course we don't build those one at a
time either we build them massively in
parallel as well we can build something
like 1 million robots on a single floor
inch wafer so for example this image on
the left this is a chip and this chip
has something like 10,000 robots on it
now in our world the macro world this
thing looks like it might be you know a
new microprocessor or something but if
you take that chip and you put it under
a microscope what you're gonna see are
thousands and thousands of tiny robots
now these robots are still stuck down
they're still attached to the surface
that we built them on in order for them
to walk around we have to release them
now we want to show you how we do that
live how we release the robot army but
the process involves highly dangerous
chemicals like like really nasty stuff
and and we're like a mile from the White
House right now yeah yeah yeah yeah they
wouldn't let us do it so uh so we're
gonna show you a movie instead what
you're looking at here are the final
stages of robot deployment we're using
chemicals to etch the substrate out from
underneath the robots when it dissolves
the robots are free to fold up into
their final shapes now you can see here
the yield is about 90% so almost every
one of those 10,000 robots we build
that's a robot that we can deploy and
control later and we can take those
robots and we can put them places as
well
so if you look at the movie on the left
that's some robots in water I'm gonna
come along with the pet and I can vacuum
them all up now when you inject the
robots back out of that pipette they're
just fine
in fact these robots are so small
they're they're small enough to pass
through the thinnest hypodermic needle
you can buy ah so if you wanted to could
inject yourself full of robots I think
they're into it okay on the right is a
robot that we put in some pond water
want you to wait for just one second
yeah you see that I was no shark I was a
Paramecium so that's the world that
these things live in okay so this is all
well and good but you might be wondering
at this point you know well did a walk
hey that's that's what they're supposed
to do they they better so let's find out
alright so here's the robot and here
it's solar cells in the middle those are
those little rectangles I want you to
look at the solar cell closest to the
top of the slide you see a little white
dot that's a laser spot now watch what
happens when we start switching that
laser between different solar cells on
the robot off it goes
off go zero about marching around the
microworld now now one of things that's
cool about this movie is I'm actually
piloting the robot in this movie in fact
for six months my job was to shoot
lasers at tiny cell sized robots to
pilot them around the micro world it was
actually my job as far as I could tell
that is the coolest job in the world is
this feeling of just total excitement
like you're doing the impossible it's a
feeling of wonder like that first time I
looked through a microscope as a kid
staring at that rotifer now I'm a dad I
have a son of my own and he's about
three years old but one day he's gonna
look through a microscope like that one
and I often wonder what is he gonna see
instead of just watching the micro world
we as humans can now build technology to
shape it to interact with it - engineer
it in 30 years when my son is my age
what would we do with that ability while
microrobots live in our bloodstream as
common as bacteria well they live on our
crops and get rid of pests well they
tell us when we have infections or will
they fight cancer cell by cell and one
cool part is you're gonna be able to
participate in this revolution ten years
or so from now when you buy your new
iPhone 15 X moto or whatever it's called
it may come with a little jar with a few
thousand tiny robots in it that you can
control by an app on your cell phone so
if you want to ride a Paramecium go for
it if you want to I don't know DJ the
world's smallest robot dance party make
it happen and and I for one am very
excited about that day coming thank you
[Applause]